Adam Levine's wife Behati Prinsloo is
pregnant with their first child
so et's Katy Kraus had to as Levine's
child went Stefani about the pair's
upcoming bundle of joy when she caught
up with the misery singer at kiss FM's
Wango Tango on Saturday I know that
Pahadi and Adam are expecting we see
pictures of you and your sons all the
time such an incredible mom are you
giving them any advice I don't look I'm
not a very good advice giver but I am
definitely been like watching her belly
grow and I'm so happy for them and I'm
so excited and Adam keeps texting me
like what about this name what about
this name like he literally keep like
and then just all that kind of stuff so
it's just really fun and it's fun
because I've had so many kids this is
what's gonna happen it's fun any names
that he's told you about feeding me like
I would tell you oh my god spill the
cheese no Stefani stayed tight-lipped
about her fellow boys coach's ideas for
his baby girl
but Levine has told ET he's ready to be
a father you're born to be a parent
that's what we're here for really
you